or we can do it is our best and
sometimes the best we can do
wizzy Avengers we gotta finish this
you trust me
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my breakdown of the Hawkeye scene
during The Avengers and game trailer
what that means for shadowing because we
have a confirmed Hawkeye phase four
series that we just got from all the
Hollywood trades we heard about it a
while ago as a rumor but now it's
finally confirmed we also found out what
Kevin Feige official stances on x-men
Fantastic Four inside the MCU and big
crossover films during Marvel phase 4
which good and bad news both but we'll
do a new bound to the IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Marvel
comment on the video we're just a couple
weeks from endgame actually hitting
theaters so it's gonna get crazier and
crazier but during the Avengers and game
trailer there's a scene where Hawkeye is
teaching his daughter to shoot a bow and
arrow on the Hawkeye family farm it's
taking place during the events after
Captain America Civil War but before the
infinity war snap he's just having a
picnic with his family you can see the
ankle bracelet that the government put
on him when he cut his deal we got this
big explainer from Scott Lang during
ant-man and the wasp about how those
ankle bracelets worked we got to see him
take it off after the government said he
was free within a really short timespan
that's when the snap happened meaning
that Hawkeye got the ankle bracelet off
when he probably had to watch his family
turn to dust that's part of the reason
why he has the giant skull Ronen tattoo
on his arm during the Avengers end game
trailer now they might embellish that a
little bit in post-production just to
make it a little more prominent but
that's where the Ronin persona comes
from he's gone super emo is super pissed
off because he lost his family and
doesn't know how to deal with it he's
just going back to his roots isn't
assassin remember Hawkeye Black Widow
during the events of the original
Avengers movie is just like Budapest
they keep talking about Budapest and all
these crazy times that they had together
when they were way more vicious Hawkeye
himself was working for Nick Fury and
shield a long time before they picked up
Black Widow and put her on the payroll
too a lot of people saw this scene of
him on the farm with his daughter
shooting the bow and because she's a
little bit older she actually looks like
Joe Russo's daughter he confirmed that
his daughter had a super secret role
during avengers endgame i won't tell you
who she's playing but it's really
special now it looks like she's playing
an older version of Hawkeye's daughter
the last time we saw her was during
Avengers age of Ultron which was
couple years ago so of course she's
gonna be way taller but a lot of people
saw this then we heard the rumors that
they were gonna do a Kate Bishop Hawkeye
series based on the map fraction run
from the comics and they're like wait a
minute is this Kate Bishop is that who
he's training here I still reiterate
that I think that this is just his
daughter and that he was just having a
fun family time just teaching her how to
shoot a bow and arrow being badass then
if this scene really does wind up being
an Avengers end game then maybe there's
a moment during the movie where he
flashes back and we see him watch his
family turn to dust
I don't know if they would actually put
that in Avengers end game but if the
movies a little over three hours long
then they definitely had time for that
Jeremy Renner's awesome as Hawkeye but
no hate on the character Hawkeye was on
my death predictions list going into
Avengers end game after infinity war
like oh he'll probably have some big
moment but I never thought that he was
gonna get his own solo movie and Jeremy
Renner is already doing a lot of other
projects he doesn't have problems
finding work in big movies they kept
hyping up that there was gonna be a big
death from one of the main Avengers
during Avengers endgame so Hawkeye was
just on the list of possibilities but
now this seems to confirm that he's
gonna be safe but I think obviously
Captain America shot way up to the top
of our predictions list but because we
haven't seen Kate Bishop anywhere in his
past he's never made a reference to her
it just sounds like he's going to be
training her after the events of
Avengers endgame so just like Spider Man
far from home guarantees that Spider Man
comes back during Avengers endgame at
some point Nick Fury comes back at some
point you could also say the same for
Hawkeye Fanus is gonna probably rake him
over the coals he'll go through hell and
back but he'll be okay if you've never
read that Matt Fraction Hawkeye run
they're obviously gonna have to change a
lot of plot points for that because
Hawkeye in the comics doesn't have a
family like that he's actually a much
younger version of the character and
he's just a pretty simple straight-up
assassin and obviously Hawkeye in the
MCU has this family the Hawkeye farm
he's a little bit older and for the most
part he doesn't kill people for hire I
mean I'm sure he's killed a lot of
really bad people for Nick Fury like
this person is a threat go take them out
that was kind of what he was assigned to
do during the first Thor film is that he
was sitting there watching Thor watching
the Hammer waiting to see if things
would go off the rails and he'd have to
take him down right now I've heard
nothing about when they're gonna start
actually shooting the series they
haven't hired any
to write it as far as we know or direct
it so unless they hire everybody on and
start shooting by the end of the year we
probably won't actually see episodes of
this Hawkeye series until 2021 it's the
same deal for the Tom Hiddleston Thor
series that he's going to be doing
during Marvel phase 4 the difference
with that series is that it's going to
be set during the past and it's gonna
jump through time and show how Loki has
affected human history quantum leap
style just slipping in and influencing
big world events throughout history much
better the other really big news that
you may have heard is the Kevin Feige
talked about what's going on with the
x-men in Fantastic Four
during Marvel phase four and is both
good and bad news so this is his quote
it says it'll be a while it's all just
beginning in the five-year plan that
we've been working on for Marvel phase
four we were working on before any of
that was set before the Fox Disney deal
closed so really it's much more for us
less about specifics of when and where
the x-men will appear right now and more
just the comfort factor of how nice it
is that they're home they're all back
but it will be a very long time then he
goes on to talk about what Marvel phase
fours slate of movies is gonna be like
he says the slate that we're building
over the next five years which is
basically his entire face floor plan is
not apples to apples compared to phase
one phase two and phase three it's two
very distinct things and I hope it'll
feel very distinct but there is a
similar mentality going into it which is
how can we continue to tell stories with
some of the characters that audiences
already know and love in a unique way in
a different way in a surprising way of
which we have a lot of plans and ideas
and work already going into it then how
can we introduce new characters that
even hardcore fans comic fans have
barely known or barely heard of that's
really exciting too so he's referring to
bringing back big core Avengers
characters for future movies like The
Black Widow movie more spider-man movies
and then obviously introducing the
really weird
characters like the Eternals that you've
never seen before right now current
Marvel phase four schedule is spider-man
far from home happening in this July
that is the very first official Marvel
phase four film than the eternal is the
Black Widow film Doctor Strange to the
shang-chi movie which is supposed to be
shooting later this year in Australia
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 in black
panther 2 so most of those films are
actually characters that you already
know about that'll be coming back during
avengers endgame it sounds like what
happened is is before he knew that he
was going to get all the x-men Fantastic
Four deadpool characters back is that
Kevin Feige was looking for a way to
reinvigorate what people think about
Marvel movies in the way they structured
things without necessarily throwing away
all the things that they did really well
or getting rid of all the characters
that people loved who were still alive
and had a lot of potential as film
franchises like Black Panther no brainer
that they're gonna do a trilogy of those
dr. strange obviously really huge
character and they can go into this big
new magical realm that they've barely
explored in the Marvel Universe
spider-man one of the most popular comic
book characters in history of course
that are going to be a ton more
spider-man appearances in movies in a
ton more spider-man solo films this is
the last gathering of The Avengers on
the show the future is very uncertain
the big difference is is they're
transitioning away from Ironman being
the center of the universe one because
they've used that character so much that
they don't want people to get tired of
them and to Robert Downey jr. is so
highly paid that it actually becomes
difficult from a production standpoint
to justify the expense if you don't
absolutely have to have him so what
probably happens is is is towards the
end of this five year period the Kevin
Feige is talking about that's when you
start to see new MCU x-men films but
there's gonna be a Deadpool movie in the
next couple of years so it's not like
none of these new Fox characters will be
doing anything for the next five years I
think people were a little confused
about that like wait a minute does that
mean no x-men at all during phase four
it just sounds like he didn't have a big
plan to cross them over and he's not
gonna try and shoe horned them in in the
next couple of years so the only big
x-men crossover stuff that I'm expecting
in the next four to five years is that
in the next couple years they announced
a new x-men film that they're making and
then they slowly start to cross those
characters over production cycle when
they announced films typically it takes
another two years for them to actually
hit screens so that's where you get to
your five-year period that he's talking
about in Marvel phase four so if you're
waiting for like big secret Wars level
crossover that sounds like it's gonna be
Marvel phase five whatever that winds up
being but here's the thing we've been
talking about people like cape bishop
there's a lot of other room in this
phase for schedules that they have not
announced yet they've been talking about
doing a young Avengers movie so when you
think about different types of things
that they've never done before in the
MCU think stuff like that we've never
seen any of the Young Avengers
characters and it sounds like they're
slowly introducing some of them in these
other big films in the next couple of
years the Avengers spin-off Disney Plus
series like the Hawkeye series the Loki
Thor series those are all can into the
MCU in the events of those movies will
influence what happens in the movies
because Kevin Feige is making all those
TV series any projects that Kevin Feige
personally works on originates and
manages are the ones that really
influence things back and forth
so obviously the movies drive everything
else but phase Forge probably the first
time you'll see TV series actually
influencing what's going on in the
movies like the Winter Soldier Falcon TV
series that's gonna take place after the
events of Avengers endgame when they're
brought back and as far as finding out
what happened in Budapest I think that
they're gonna deal with that during the
Black Widow movie where we'll get a hint
of that but I don't think that's gonna
absolutely take place entirely in
Budapest I believe they're gonna be
shooting that somewhere in New Orleans
and actually David Harbor was talking
about them starting to shoot that in
June so we should find out more about
what's going on with the Black Widow
movie what period it's set during in the
next couple of months there was also a
recent interview where Robert Downey jr.
made fun of Kevin Feige for his level of
secrecy because they were all
questioning Black Widow about it I
believe it was on Jimmy Kimmel movie
shooting anyway when does the Black
Widow movie start shooting well why the
one you're in the Black Widow movie you
know your own like movie everybody's had
their own movie and you haven't had your
own movie but I assume you're gonna have
your own
it's too much work in many words what if
I can share the other we haven't
announced that I was like talking about
it what are you talking about you can
see Black Widow sort of dodging the
question a little bit like yeah of
course we all know that you're getting
ready to shoot the Black Widow movie but
officially they can't say anything about
it until Kevin Feige officially says
something about it but as Robert Downey
jr. says everyone's talking about it we
all know exactly what's going on
there'll be more Avengers endgame stuff
happening this week there was a whole
bunch of news the last couple of days in
Game of Thrones episode one is airing on
Sunday night so get ready because I'll
be doing videos for all that stuff it's
gonna be crazy while you wait for
everything click here to rewatch that
Avengers end game opening scene a
billion more times and click here to
start getting ready for Game of Thrones
season 8 episode 1 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]